so the last time last lecture I ended
with the Abrahamic stories with the
death of Sarah and that was Abraham's
wife and so we're gonna continue from
from there remember Abraham had a son
Isaac and he was asked by God to
sacrifice his son which we talked about
in in some depth and I was attempting to
make the case that you know the idea of
sacrifice was one of humankind's great
discoveries because it meant the
discovery of the future essentially but
it also meant the discovery that the
future was something that you could make
a bargain with and that you could give
up something now something impulsive
some pleasure even a deep pleasure in
the moment and you could strive and
hypothetically you could make a covenant
a bargain with the future and if your
sacrifices were acceptable and that
seemed to mean an ethically acceptable
you had to sacrifice the right thing
that that vastly increased the
probability that not only you would be
successful let's say but that your
descendants would be too and I don't
think that that's an irrational
proposition I mean you have to leave in
it a bit with the realization that
sometimes you know you get sliced off at
the knees no matter what right because
life has an arbitrary element and and
that can't be tossed out but building in
the arbitrary element will say you still
want to think well what's your best bet
given a certain amount of randomness and
it seems to me that conscious self-aware
sacrifice and proper ethical striving is
your best bet and you know there's
another idea that well I've always
explained it when I've explained it to
people I've always used the movie
Pinocchio as an example you know that
when Geppetto was trying to make his
puppet into a self-aware and autonomous
moral agent which is what he wants above
all else you know he aims at the highest
good that he can conceive which is the
star that he prays to essentially and
hopes for the transformation and there's
also something in that that's
unutterably profound and maybe that is
somewhat independent of the idea that
you
have to believe in God I would also say
that what it means to believe in God in
the Old Testament is by no means clear
and that's something I also really want
to talk about tonight it's not obvious
what it means and well Gepetto what he
does at least is aim at the highest good
of which he can conceive you know and
that that's actually being a
philosophical definition of God upon
occasion that God is the highest good of
which you conceived and you know that's
different than the idea of a
transcendent being precisely but it's in
line with it's in line with certain
interesting psychoanalytic speculations
this is one of the things I really liked
about Carl Jung you know